En qué se basa su advertencia sobre el
aumento de temperaturas qué podría pasar
a corto plazo en el continente americano
bueno Muchas gracias por la oportunidad
la Organización meteorológica Mundial a
través de todas sus redes centros
globales y regionales y el intercambio
de datos a nivel mundial viene haciendo
continuamente un análisis y un monitoreo
del sistema climático Y hoy por hoy el
día de hoy se publicó un reporte que se
hace en colaboración con la oficina
meteorológica del Reino Unido hacia un
pronóstico de hacia los cinco años de
las temperaturas globales de los de las
temperaturas globales en el en el
planeta y justamente en ese análisis
basado en todo lo que se ha venido
analizando con los datos históricos se
prevé que hay muchísimas probabilidades
hay de hecho 98% de probabilidades que
en los próximos cinco años alcancemos
este esta base de los 1.5 grados
centígrados establecido en los acuerdos
de París por encima de los promedios
preindustriales entonces a esto hay que
agregarle que hay más certeza sobre esta
esta proyección tomando cuenta que hoy
por hoy estamos ya experimentando las lo
que es la evolución de un fenómeno del
niño que se viene que se viene
evidenciando en el Pacífico Tropical y
que posiblemente comience su desarrollo
ya en los próximos meses y tenga el
máximo desarrollo al finales de a
finales de año la última vez el periodo
más cálido registrado en los
históricamente fue el 2016 justamente
cuando tuvimos un fenómeno del niño
importante sumado al incremento de
temperaturas globales por el cambio
climático estas esta situación se podría
repetir en este año y los efectos en la
temperatura global sentirse en el 2024 y
poder alcanzar posiblemente ese uno
punto cinco grados centígrados y
particularmente aquí en el continente
americano en que se podría Traducir este
aumento de la temperatura global
los impactos de este de la temperatura
se traduce en efectos adversos para
sectores la salud especialmente la salud
de los sectores más vulnerables los
recursos hídricos la agricultura
la infraestructura en sí y una de las
cosas que se prevé con el evento el niño
además es que por un lado en ciertas
regiones de la de latinoamérica Como por
ejemplo Ecuador Perú centro de chile el
sureste de Sudamérica tengamos lluvias
más pronunciadas Pero por otro lado en
otras regiones como el norte de
Sudamérica Centroamérica buena parte del
Caribe más bien hay un déficit de
lluvias sequías asociadas también con
altas temperaturas y y la influencia que
podría tener esto sobre la temporada de
huracanes en en este año es decir que
tenemos hoy por hoy desde el punto de
vista científico evidencia muy sólida de
lo que se viene para los próximos meses
y es importante que los gobiernos las
autoridades Tomen las previsiones del
caso para mitigar al máximo los los
impactos adversos de de los efectos del
clima en toda la región y el mundo pero
ni precisamente le pregunto por esto que
usted comentaba brevemente Qué medidas
deben tomar las autoridades
Yo creo que el evento del del niño él
nos ha dejado muchas lecciones en el
pasado tuvimos hemos tenido muchos
eventos ya muy bien registrados el 82 83
el 97 98 2015 2016 una de las grandes
ventajas si se lo puede decir así del
evento el niño es que es un evento de
lenta evolución que permite la adecuada
preparación de los gobiernos es decir
con este escenario que se está
planteando con la evidencia científica
que se está presentando es importante
que los gobiernos tomen medidas
preventivas preventivas contar con el la
intención de poder generar a política
pública y todas las previsiones de punto
de vista presupuestario de desde el
punto de vista de coordinación
interinstitucional para hacer frente a
los eventos asociados con el evento el
niño en cada uno de los países esta
respuesta anticipada planificada
definitivamente es lo que buscaríamos de
todos los gobiernos de de de la región
Especialmente los más afectados los más
sensibles a los impactos del fenómeno
del niño